Speaker 1: Let's go to Ryan from
DC. Ryan from D.C., welcome to the
program. What's on your mind today?
Speaker 2: Hey, David, great to talk
to you again. I spoke with you a couple of
times. So appreciated my audio. Okay. Welcome.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you're audio is fine.
Speaker 2: All right. Perfect. I wanted to
just ask you a policy related question, but around
I mean, I know there's been a lot of news coming
out in the last 2 to 3 months with AGP and some of
the language learning models that are now coming
out for companies to use in kind of a proprietary
way their own in-house data. And I, I was looking
at some of the interviews. I know that Open
Air CEO just recently had a big interview with
with CNBC. And my question is really around
the economy and job replacement. You know,
it seems that Chargeability for just recently
released and, you know, the improvement is not
linear. It is exponential. And it seems like are
the guardrails from a policy perspective are just
not only are they not there, but knowing that the
pace in which our government typically operates is
not at all exponential. And so I have a concern
around the economy taking a significant hit and
just this being such disruptive technology. I'm
wondering how do we kind of galvanize legislators,
especially legislators that are not technically
inclined to really kind of listen to some of the
thought leaders in the technology space that we
need to get these guardrails in place? Do you
think that that is a topic that could be relevant
in the upcoming election cycle? It seems that I
mean, I work in the technology space, so I might
be a little bit a little bit more focused on some
of the upcoming changes. But I guess from what
I've seen, you know, just from what I've seen,
I mean, this is incredibly disruptive technology
and could easily, you know, replace large swaths
of the white collar workforce for sure.
Speaker 1: So here's the deal. First of all,
on the potential to replace large swaths
of the workforce, there are two views on
this. I'll tell you what they are, and then
I'll kind of give you my take. One view is,
I think, closer to what you're suggesting, which
is that this technology is so disruptive that it
is going to be unlike anything in the past and
it's job destroying potential. It is going to
eliminate entire areas of work and replace it with
technology and lead to technological unemployment
potentially irreversibly. That's one view. On the
other side, there's the view that says, you know,
every time in history that something like this
has come along when there started to be cars and
people said, what's going to happen with all the
horse buggy drivers, they'll have nothing to do.
Well, the car industry brought with it the need
for mechanics and more chauffeurs and all these
different new industries were created, delivery
services, etc. The technology eliminated some
jobs, but it created more. Okay, so those are
the two extremes. Now, the difference may be
and there are some technologists who say
this is the case, that where we are now,
these are now destructive technologies from the
point of view of employment, That's something like
chat GPT. It's not going to create more jobs than
it destroys. That's what some people say. It's not
obvious to me. I don't I don't have an answer to
this yet because it is absolutely the case that
there are tons of things, including in customer
service and research and things that if chat,
GPT and those technologies get better, they still
spit out wrong information regularly right now.
But if they get better, it's true. There are
lots of jobs that would be destroyed. But for
people who know how to use these tools to draw new
connections between things and generate new ideas,
there are still there's still the possibility
that they will actually create new jobs in
industries we haven't even thought of yet. So
I just don't think I'm in a position yet to say
whether it will be the destructive force some
fear it will be, or whether it will be a great
thing or it will be more like Neil Postman says,
which is there will be good and there will be bad,
and it will come down to how it's regulated.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I completely agree. And
those are definitely the two schools of
thought. I think a lot of the concern,
at least in the technology space, is
especially that the difference in the
distinguishing factor between the kind of
AI revolution and things like the industrial
revolution that created net new jobs is
that the pace of improvement with AI is
exponential in such a exponential way That
is unlike any other technological revolution
we've experienced in all of human history.
Speaker 1: Yeah, that's the argument that
some are making, like I outlined.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah. So anyway,
I just was thinking about that. I'm wondering if,
you know, from a policy perspective, you know,
that if we do start to see some employment
getting replaced, if that will be a relevant
topic for politicians in the upcoming cycles.
Speaker 1: I think it should be. I think it
should be, but I don't know that it will be.
Speaker 2: Got it. Hey, David, thanks again for
taking my call. Great to speak with you.
Speaker 1: All right. There is Ryan from
D.C.. Very, very, very important topic. And
eventually it's going to be a huge issue